well the mainline Peter Parker books may
have disappointed me for the last time
but at least there's another Spidey out
there that's still going strong he's
half-latino and has a red and black
costume yes someone you all know his
name starts with an m
please welcome the other Spider-Man
Miguel O'Hara
after Decades of being in the peripheral
of Spider-Man's immense success as a
franchise Miguel O'Hara the Spider-Man
of the year 2099 is finally in a
starring role in a big Hollywood film
and with that I'm sure a lot more people
are looking to get into the character's
history in comics luckily for you he's
barely had any books compared to Peter
and Miles so tracking down and reading
his entire catalog should be a
relatively easy task as someone who read
all of his books years ago and has been
eagerly waiting for more opportunities
to shove them down your throat because
of how good they are I shall be your
guide as we delve into his history and I
give you reading recommendations as well
as a few personal opinions on the runs
to help inform your journey to this
cyberpunk dystopia let's go to the
futuristic world of oh Jesus it's only
70 years away now to a society where Dr
Doom is President corporations own the
police in a way more overt way than even
Robocop and the definition of the color
black has shifted slightly welcome to
Nueva York
find out more after a quick word from
today's sponsor special thanks to
bespoke posts for sponsoring this video
bespoke post is a monthly membership
club delivering a box of awesome top
shelf goods from under the radar Brands
it's free to join and you can skip a
month or cancel anytime ninety percent
of the products come from small Brands
many of which are based right here in
the US the American barbecue rub in the
carnivore box is made by the Great
American Spice company in Rockford
Michigan every month they introduce
their members to cool new products
outdoor gear barware home and kitchen
goods clothing and even more like live
oysters based on our preference quiz
they fill out every box of awesome has
around 70 dollars worth of goods Inside
the Box because you only a fraction of
the value preview your box before it's
shipped you'll get a box of awesome
assigned to you and before it's shipped
you'll get a preview of what comes
inside to decide if you'd like to one
keep it two swap it for a different box
or three skip that month entirely for no
charge you only pay for what you want I
got the fuel box with a versus tile mini
camping stove and a handy Blended spice
container to liven up any meal you make
on the go I also got the parked box that
comes with a comfy camp chair that can
be folded up smaller than a shoe box for
Easy Storage during travel to get 20 off
your first box of awesome click the link
in the description and enter godzilla20
at checkout or go to bespoke.com forward
slash Godzilla 20. now back to the video
naturally the first book we'll be going
over is the 46 issue original run of
Spider-Man 2099 by Peter David from
1992. one of the nicest things about
this run is that it has nothing to do
with any previous Spider-Man storylines
at all you don't need to know a damn
thing about Peter Parker or his history
to just jump straight into this which is
nice because it allows this story and
world to really stand on their own
Miguel O'Hara is a young scientist
working for the massively powerful
massively corrupt alchemax on a secret
experiment with the intention to
recreate Spider-Man's powers
for corporate Espionage unfortunately
though Peter's secret identity was taken
to his grave they don't have any of his
DNA on file and it's been so long that
they can only make guesses at how some
of his powers worked so there are
attempts at recreating them turn out a
bit
let's say messy even if the FDA would
still probably approve of super strong
mutant Guerrilla men that kill people
Miguel has had enough with this mad
science and tries to quit his job to go
work at Future McDonald's instead but
his evil boss Tyler Stone ensures his
obedience by drugging him with a highly
addictive narcotic called Rapture which
is presumably produced in the same
Factory as drops red sand spice and nuke
in order to cure himself of his
dependence on Rapture Miguel sneaks into
the lab where he works to rewrite his
own DNA but his jealous co-worker tries
to stop the Endeavor and ends up
accidentally turning Miguel into the
first and only successful half-man half
spider produced by alcamax terrific you
know it'll cost me a fortune but I have
to start buying all my clothes made from
unstable molecules fabric otherwise one
wrong move and rip only thing I own made
from umf is this death's head costume I
bought when I went to Mexico last year
for the DIA dos Muertos Festival can get
pretty wild I wanted something extra
sturdy from that day forward he dons at
Dia de Muertos costume that he wore to
Mexico the previous year and uses his
powers to take on the evils of alchemax
and its CEO Tyler Stone his webbing's
organic his ability to stick to walls
comes from Barbed Talons in his hands
and feet and he has fangs and eyes
sensitive to light because of how acute
his eyesight is the movie really nailed
it by saying he's a ninja vampire
Spider-Man but a good guy the biggest
strength of this run for me is how much
of a departure it is from classic
Spider-Man while Peter Parker struggles
with his Public Image and is often
treated by the media as some kind of
villain Miguel is seen as a freedom
fighting Outlaw that inspires the people
of Nueva York
people in the streets dress up as him
which is ironically pretty easy because
his costume is store-bought not
something he made himself and they
protest alchemax and the corporate
police known as the public eye with his
image as a symbol of battling oppression
not only that but Miguel's personality
from the jump is so distinct from
Peter's he gets his powers as a grown
adult rather than a teenager and he's
much more of a cynic than his superhero
namesake he's really sarcastic and
bitter when he's in his civilian
identity often throwing mean Jabs and
dark humor at the people he encounters
gentlemen I couldn't help but over here
Mr Stone
not long enough no C but Aaron here is
correct alcamax wants results
Alco Max can't want anything Thai it's a
corporation a legal thing only humans
can have human desires and humans have
to be aware that Reckless testing on
human subjects might be if my father
were alive today you know what he'd say
help help get me out of this coffin it's
a caution is the first Refuge of the
coward
okay Mig you want to tell me what's
going on
it's so dark in here
what's happened to you what did that
company of yours do to you
Dana said you were strung out on Rapture
whatever happened to hi Big Brother
how's it going why are you mumbling
because I've grown phones
if I open my mouth too hard you'll see
them
now will you shut up a minute haha very
funny
so you think to defy he who is called
blood Hammer I thought it was blood
sword
BS short not anymore
C is the hammer
is the blood blood Hammer whatever but
when he puts the costume on he's all
business and he takes his role as a
superhero very seriously it's a really
cool reversal of Peter's wisecracking
schtick he's a really well-defined
character and it makes it all the more
exciting to read a Spider-Man book
that's so divorced from the conventions
of the original
nothing about Miguel is trying to
recreate Peter at all he's just
so much his own thing during this 45
issue run Spidey bumps into a few other
2099 books from around the time for
Crossovers and cross promotion so we
gotta add these to the list too just to
clarify the story stuff during the fall
of hammer event Arc some might say it's
important to keep up on that to get the
full story and it's some nice additional
World building for 20.99 so you know
what other characters are running around
there but you can mostly just get the
Recaps from Miguel's main issues too if
you really don't want to get bogged down
in the event after his initial 46 issue
run the popularity of the 2099 line of
comics started dwindle as several of its
writers including Peter David quit
writing these books to protest Joey
Cavalieri being fired from Marvel you
can tell something shifted near the end
because the last two issues of the
original run had a different writer from
the rest of the book and Miguel's
suddenly quipping like Peter and nothing
really feels right plus much like the
other big Goblin related story arc from
just before this and new writer came in
and accidentally screwed up the big
reveal of the mystery Goblin villain's
identity and picked a character who it
was never intended to be can't believe
this happened twice back then buddy and
the rest of the 2099 folks were wrapping
up most of their books a lot of these
characters haven't been killed off by Dr
Doom including like Hulk 2099 and kind
of Punisher 2099 he's a little confusing
all of the surviving 2099 Heroes had
their books folded into a single comic
called 2099 World of Tomorrow that ran
only for eight issues before being
canceled if you're going for
completionist then I'd throw this one
into since it directly follows at the
end of Miguel's book but it also follows
up everyone's books so there's a lot of
other characters here like X-Men 2099
and an allegedly time traveling
Fantastic Four and it can get a little
hard to keep up with if you're not
informed about everything going on with
those characters as well
personally I found it hard to get into
because there was just so much going on
and Spidey gets so little page time
compared to everyone else now this book
is totally non-canon at this point
or I mean it kind of is it's confusing
but all of these series lead into one
final one shot called 2099 Manifest
Destiny that really Narrows in on
Spider-Man and offers a potential
definitively happy ending for his story
where he teams up with a twice Frozen
Captain America and discovers he's
worthy of Thor's hammer
what do you think
is the request
and I'm gonna honor it no matter what
whosoever holds this Hammer if he be
worthy
Miguel uses his Newfound power to lead
the severely damaged world of 2099 into
a peaceful utopian future as its
benevolent ruler it's actually the most
hopeful potential future for the Marvel
Universe I've ever seen it's neat stuff
but it can't really fit into the comics
anymore since later books would
contradict this and create more stories
with him as just regular Spider-Man in
the future and take away this whole
world-ending flood thing that happened
it is nice to have a good what if to
wrap it all up though and I do really
like this one so check it out even if
you skip the World of Tomorrow book this
is where the character's popularity was
likely at an all-time low and besides a
few stray action figures and varied
costumes and video games he really
wasn't appearing that much though we do
have a good list of Minor appearances
written once again in part by Peter
David to fill in the gap before Miguel
Rose back to prominence in the 2010s
first is Peter David's Captain Marvel
book that he used as a gateway to close
up his old projects that got left on an
awkward note and he has some of the cast
members of this book traveled to 2099 at
what seems like a point before a lot of
irreversible damage hadn't been done the
city's in perfect shape no flood a
character that was permanently paralyzed
is still walking here it's following up
directly on one of 2099's early
storylines and so on You could argue
this little time travel event changed
the outcome of 2099 to render all that
near apocalypse stuff non-canon and I
like to think that's how Miguel has been
able to come back since his story was
pretty much over
now from this point forward it's been
altered and we're watching a different
version of his future play out hey big
points to the colorist of this issue for
understanding the assignment and
actually coloring him black and red hey
by the way like any terrible running
joke on this channel I've turned that
into a t-shirt so go hit that link in
the description if you want to grab one
anyway yeah this is a neat little side
John even though I don't really know
anything about Captain Marvel this is by
far one of my favorite stories to
include Miguel because of the snappy
script and the really fantastic art
but after that an alternate Miguel has a
stint as a member of the Exiles a group
of Heroes from all around the Multiverse
that have been plucked from their home
Dimensions to save the day of all the
non-peter David written appearances of
Miguel this is probably my favorite
because it captures his voice decently
well and it's just cool to see him on a
team running around geeking out at the
science of all these strange new worlds
okay we're outside space and time
surrounded by nothingness so there's no
vantage point from which you could see
our exterior yeah
but my head hurts just thinking about it
my theory of the timeline diverging from
the original run happens once again with
this version of him referencing an event
from the original book is happening just
a few weeks ago in Hulk 2099 hasn't been
killed off yet
I'm not sure where the exact point of
Divergence is but this seals the deal of
being a new variant of O'Hara that goes
down a different path so it's all
Uncharted Territory now for Miguel's
story going forward and his time with
the Exiles is really cool this is the
first time I've really tried to read any
of the Exiles books and it's a neat
premise not sure why these guys aren't
more prevalent at the moment considering
everything has to be about the
Multiverse stuff now I'm sure there's
gonna be an exile show after the Kang
Dynasty or whatever this whole book does
set up Miguel's spider Society in the
movies because the Exiles run around
trying to preserve the course of history
in different universes to stop them from
collapsing and naturally they're also
kind of bad at that too I definitely
recommend this run and all the issues
too not just the ones with Miguel of
front and center seeing cool stuff like
the heroic version of Galactus or
counter Earth they have a story where
all the Wolverines are united in a
spider-verse-like event and this was in
2006. be warned though that the last 10
issues of this run switches Riders and
it starts to get a little messy in order
to quickly wrap things up Chris
Claremont I love you but this was not
your best work and while this ends up
being a Divergent path for Miguel's
story and isn't really Canon to the main
line Series this version of him does
show up again in later 2099 books and
the first spider-verse event but enough
about the Exiles also timestorm is just
another Universe with a teenage Miguel
and it's not very good so we'll skip
over that but like you know it's right
here if you want to check it out now
we're going to talk about Miguel's
triumphant return to the mainstream
first it started with the double whammy
of Shattered Dimensions and Edge of Time
creating a whole new generation of fans
by introducing them to him and getting
them even more confused about colors
then Dan slot the writer of Shattered
Dimensions decide to pull Miguel back
into the mainline Amazing Spider-Man
comics during the superior Arc after
discovering he's Marty McFly into
nothingness Miguel has to go back to the
present day to stop his grandfather from
being killed in a race his family line
age
what have they done now look at all of
those encouragers into the fabric of
space-time why would they do that are
they insane they broke all of time but
that's me
and I'm wearing that device
but I haven't put it on yet
hey time travel
all right
so what's so special about 2013 he
serves as a nice foil for Otto Octavius
as Spidey because he's equally as
grouchy but a lot more morally upright
you thought Miguel had some questionable
superhero ethics he's Superman compared
to Otto who is shooting villains Point
Blank creating an overly surveilled
police state and spanking his monkey to
Peter's memories of MJ's butt
Superior Superior ended and Peter was
restored to his body Miguel was stranded
in the present for spider-verse and even
two more volumes of his solo book once
again penned by none other than Peter
David these two runs are great if only
because it's so satisfying to have Peter
David riding this Spidey in the long
term again and having him encounter
stuff in the present day that he'd never
seen his original series though after a
while I do miss the world and setting of
Nueva York but with the ever reverting
status quo of Marvel Comics you just
know he'll get back there eventually
another big drawback of this run is that
the art style is like
Trace 3D models and tends to look a
little stiff
they color him so Shocking Blue during
the middle of this he also gets sucked
into all the dumb Secret Wars in Civil
War 2 event stuff so you can read those
two for completion but it's not
necessary
unfortunately Miguel O'Hara's Creator
Peter David has had a lot of health
issues in the last decade and has had
less and less time to devote to writing
comics
currently he's not doing so well so if
you get a chance you should donate to
his family's GoFundMe to help him get
back on his feet I met him and
interviewed him at a convention a few
years ago and he was so incredibly nice
and accommodating to my dumb obscure
questions and weird sense of humor I was
like 16 or 17 at the time and he totally
didn't have to give such in-depth
responses to that dumb kid but he was so
kind what color is Miguel O'Hara's suit
is it blue or is it black it's blue
black
he's easily one of my favorite comic
writers and I know he's a great guy so
please do whatever you can to help him
out with any extra expenses they'll
still be dealing with even if he's been
off the book for a while spidey2099 is
more popular now than he ever has been
and is likely going to just keep on
trucking into the year 2099. at that
point they should just retitle it to
Spider-Man or
push the year forward so he's like
Spider-Man 3099 and it's harder for
everyone to say it's not accurate to
what the real world looks like yeah they
could have renamed it to Nueva York and
invented flying cars somewhere in there
it's a thousand years No One's Gonna Be
able to call out Futurama for being an
inaccurate depiction of the future
regardless Miguel's showing up here and
there since then with a story in Nick
Spencer's Spider-Man run a one shot and
a few solo books since then that I'll
throw in there too so you can keep up
with them this era is where they commit
to a full reboot of the entire 2099
Universe not even like an implied one
but a really really overt storyline
about that but Miguel gets to keep a
fair amount of his memories of the old
version of everything and his previous
Adventures thanks to yet another time
traveling version of himself that lived
to old age but kept his hair this time
we're now on the third version of him
because of all these branching timelines
but I just like him so much that I don't
care I think it's because they need him
to stay in the year 29 89 and if his
character progresses too far the year is
going to change and it'll shock up his
branding
you know Spider-Man 2100 doesn't sound
as good
I mean x-ben 92 takes place in 1997.
it's just a name stop overthinking it
guys unfortunately he hasn't had a full
ongoing since the last Peter David book
ended but with across the spider verse
bringing his popularity to new heights
on the big screen and everyone on
Twitter collectively cranking hog to his
tight Latino vampire butt
I'm sure we're going to see a new number
one any day now he's also got a big
storyline where he gets the Venom
symbiote coming up so throw that on the
list too if you're starting any of these
books now or you've already read some of
them be sure to tell me which stories
with spidey2099 were your favorite and
also feed the algorithm with more
fruitless debates about whether or not
blue or black is better also don't
forget to pick up that shirt oh
[Music]
thank you